Hello everybody. Uh, this is my very
first time attempting something like
this, so I'm obviously a little bit
nervous. Um,
but you can only learn by doing. So,
here I am doing something that I've
never done before. Uh the reason why I
decided to make this video and this
channel uh by extension is because I'm
sick and tired of seeing uh
misinformation
um especially historical misinformation
uh very often generated by AI that um
have these like crazy fantastical
uh claims that uh rot your brain or that
that are interesting maybe to watch
because they they they are just so
spectacular but that have very little
basis in u the historical re reality.
They don't post their sources or they
misinterpreted sources. Um,
and um, I'm passionate about about
history and the historical process. And
it pains me often to to see people uh,
propagate some claims that that are
known, at least in the historical
community, to be false. And then there's
very good reason why they are false.
But just because somebody decided to
make like a viral video, um,
bringing forth a couple of sources that
are like misinterpreted, uh, they get
like, you know, 10 million views and
everybody watches it and they think it's
like cool and edgy and and flashy. So,
this is what I'm going to try and
combat, I guess. Um, my my goal um would
be to provide some kind of
counterbalance. Um, I know that very
often history is seen as a very boring
subject. Um, especially in high school.
Um, history teachers are either super
passionate and everybody loves them or
they are like the most boring dry people
ever that just expect you to cram a
bunch of dates in in in your head and um
yeah, basically turn you into a parrot.
uh and I hope to be the the the the
first uh version of of of that teacher.
I'm not a history teacher although I do
tutor it but like I said I am very
passionate about uh the subject and I
think especially nowadays where um
narrative
myths and and um national myths as well
are so important
um I do think it's important to provide
some kind of counterbalance and to
provide you with sources and means to
basically uh figure uh things out for
yourself. You don't have to take my word
for it, but please look into these uh
things that that people are posting
because some of them are just not true.
Uh as part of this process, I am also
learning how to become
a YouTuber, an influencer. Um I'm I'm
learning how to edit videos. I'm
learning how to publish videos, how to
market market them, I guess, to reach as
many people as possible. And um yeah,
included at the end of this intro will
probably be a time lapse of my very
first le lesson of Da Vinci Resolve.
That's the program that I've kind of
settled on to to to learn. Um so yeah,
there will be a time lapse, I hope, if I
learn how to do that. uh it will not be
perfect. Uh so please uh send me
constructive feedback in the comments. I
think that that's how people do it. And
um if you come across like uh insane
claims on social media that have gone
viral um send them my way. I I I try to
stay away from as much Brainard as
possible. Um but I think I will have to
interact with it. So please send it my
way. uh please uh ask me to debunk
something even if you believe it. Uh
it's always good to have like a to get a
second opinion of somebody like looking
critical at at your um sources I guess.
So thank you very much. I hope you stick
around and I will see you in the second
episode where I will be uh hopefully if
I've learned how to edit a little bit um
where I will be looking at the claim of
some Russian historians and by Vladimir
Putin himself actually um that uh
Ukraine never had statethood and that um
Russians and Ukrainians are basically
the same people. There's a lot to say
about it. Uh, I will not do it here, but
uh that's a small teaser for next
episode. See you. Hope you stick around.
[Music]
Heat. Heat.
Hey,
[Music]
hey, hey.
Hey. Hey. Hey.
[Music]